[Music]
this year we're visiting a new locale
Dorn for the first time we've met some
Dornish folks before Oberyn Martell and
hilarious and and Oberon sadly did not
make it through season four we travel as
far south as South goes as they say in
Westeros and visit his family the
Martel's who are the ruling House of
Dorne we had a hit last year the
characters reintroduced from Dorne and
so this year we have the challenge of
creating a place that was luxurious and
pleasant and warm a place where people
enjoyed themselves this is a new country
for Game of Thrones so it's it's
exciting
well it feels like Dorn was always meant
to be
a vaguely Mediterranean country because
the key location was the water gardens
we wanted to find someplace where the
gardens really were remarkable Seville
in spine was the natural place for us to
stop and we were absolutely beyond lucky
being able to shoot in the alcázar once
we found out we were allowed to shoot in
the Royal Gardens we realized that
there's nowhere on earth that looks more
like the water gardens as we'd pictured
them than this place I think only one
movie has been permitted to shoot there
before for a very limited time we got to
shoot there for an entire week and both
in the gardens and in a room that's
maybe the most spectacular room I've
ever seen some of the spaces that we
were filming in were 500 years old and
they have that kind of ancient culture
that they were looking for but also the
opulence it's the kind of thing you
could never build as a set as the shoot
sort of moved through they would close
off you know certain corners so we could
have it to ourselves and not be
interrupted by the public but what it
meant was that we had these
extraordinary gardens to ourselves and
we're just incredibly grateful to the
Spanish government for letting us shoot
him truly one of the most beautiful
places I've ever seen your brother was
murdered you sit here in your water
gardens staring at the sky and doing
nothing malaria is a hot-blooded woman
and she wants revenge and so she returns
to Dorne seeking revenge and there we
meet oberyn's brother the Prince of
Dorne Prince Doran he's very good at
playing the political game you're not
quite sure what he's going to do or not
do about the death of his brother what
will you do about his death I will bury
him
I wouldn't mourn for him and then Duran
is a real diplomat you know he's someone
who's trying to make peace all the time
he doesn't want to lead his country into
war he'll be charming and mean it but
he'll be keeping something in reserve
you haven't had to use that ex of yours
in a long time no bad friends
Jota teased this mountain of a man who
makes sure that I don't get into trouble
I hope you remember how I remember he is
the right-hand man to the Prince of
Dorne
his whole motto is serve protect and
obey and we meet the sand snakes for
three of over and say daughters you must
choose the rands way and peace on my way
and war NIMH is oberyn's middle child
younger sister is tyene older sister is
a bara and where the sand snakes we work
very well as a unit and fight love to
fight a very violent we learn there from
our father
Taine's a youngest one she's the
daughter of ilaria she knows us very
well she knows how much we want revenge
football garena follow me
she manages to make just focus on her
mission I play Obara sand and I will a
spear which is the same as Oberyn
Martell and I'm area has a whip and
daggers and tyene has double daggers the
first time I went to stunt training we
weren't sure who was gonna have what so
I tried out the whip which is really
really hard and just not really right
for my body and size and everything and
then I tried the daggers I was like oh
yeah this is my weapon
I'd never touched a whip before then and
it's a proper it's an 8-foot bullwhip
the real one I injured myself more than
anyone else in those first sessions I've
been training in the martial art of
wushu which was the training that Pedro
Pascal had as well even though they will
have different methods or different
ideals of how they'll avenge oberyn's
death essentially it is gonna be easier
if they will work together that's
another of my problems just keeping
these kids on it control I complicated
nieces young man said I'd find the high
Sparrow back he where is he high Sparrow
sound ridiculous doesn't one of the
biggest rolls this season is the high
Sparrow and we were incredibly excited
when we heard that Jonathan Pryce might
be interested in the part and the even
more excited when we saw him start to
work the high Sparrow is one of the more
intriguing and fascinating characters I
think in all of a Song of Ice and Fire
and again one that we've been itching to
get to I'm driven solely by faith yeah
I'm very honest and honorable intentions
and everything I do which of course
makes other people in the show distrust
him even more because they can't believe
that anyone would actually be honest
everyone's playing some kind of secret
game
hypocrisy is a boil lancing a boil is
never Pleasant these are bad people they
need they need cleansing as you've seen
in previous seasons across the Narrow
Sea I have nowhere else to go
you have everywhere else to go but wait
the seasons one the biggest in terms of
new sets and house of black and white
where Arya spends a lot of time in
Braavos is when his locations from the
books we were always excited to get to
there's been those new sets built
specifically for arias storyline which
is really really cool the exterior of
the house in black and white is in
Dubrovnik around the water that location
was amazing we were literally right on
the water's edge and the set that they
built was huge
when I arrived she really has no idea
where she is the doors to the house of
black and white where to I can't even
put it into words how massive they were
or the exterior that we actually built
out in Croatia we created a facade that
from my perspective was faceless I
didn't want it to give away at all what
was housed inside she first enters into
the atrium which is very high ceiling
and in this weird oval shape and the
perimeter of it is surrounded by
different gods the house of black and
white is a repository of the thousands
of gods that have ever been worshipped
throughout all the lands that we visit
and Game of Thrones and depth took that
idea and ran with it the house of the
black and white was a huge challenge for
Deb Riley and her team I just thought
she did such beautiful work on each one
of the different gods that people come
to pray to in the way that they were
arranged in the space and the way they
defined the space and the gorgeous
creepy dark pool in the middle of the
room and what the room tries to do is to
remain neutral enough that these
sculptures can sit there and each have
the same level of importance it's one
thing to describe a place on paper and
quite another for
and your team to actually build the
place that's going to provide that
atmosphere for the viewers and you just
want to write more and more scenes for
those locations
[Music]